every salesperson knows every sales
person who's worth their salt knows that
sales is in large part about
relationships you know it's just it's
not it's not just a list of prices and
product attributes you know that that's
when you you've become a commodity
um and every good salesperson knows that
if you have a strong relationship with a
client
um with a customer and the company
screws up
you know you get a delivery time wrong
um or let's say your price is slightly
higher than a comparable product that's
open on the market that's available on
the market it's the relationship that
that uh that that client that customer
wants to keep doing business with you
even if it's a higher price and even if
you screw up now and then because they
know fundamentally you're good people
that you have their backs and you're
going to try for them like every sales
person knows that right well if we know
that that's the case with our customers
and our clients then the same logic
applies to our colleagues which is it's
the relationships if you want to
guarantee that someone's loyal if you
want to guarantee that someone's going
to be there for you put in that extra
mile then it's the quality of the
relationship it's the exact same skill
so this is what's I think actually sales
people have a head start in terms of
leadership training because they know
how to build relationships now just
apply that internally one of the things
that I learned from Jack Daly who's a
famous sales coach is he said the
average number of questions asked in a
bad sales meeting is about seven where
the average number of questions asked a
good sales meeting is about 32. and so
it's not coming in and just throwing up
you know a product attributes or what
what we can give you because that's all
about you it's about learning to listen
and learning uh to pay attention and
goes back to those listening skills and
at the c-level executives you know we
don't know what their stressors are you
know there are some Basics they know
they need to do basic security because
that's the world we live in but why you
over somebody else and by asking
questions and listening not to try and
find a way to to get your product in
there but to genuinely genuinely
genuinely try to help them solve a
problem the best sales people sometimes
say you know what
I hear what you're what you're trying to
do and I'll be honest with you
um we're not very good at that but I'm
gonna put you in touch with somebody who
is that builds trust
um you know I'll I'll tell you a funny
story with me when I was starting my
career uh and I started my my I had a
marketing consultancy it was my my first
little business that I started I
remember coming from the advertising
world where we would talk to clients and
we would tell them we were great at
everything when we weren't
um and Trust would very quickly
deteriorate because they would find out
very quickly that we were junk in
something that we claimed we were good
we got the sale good but we destroyed
the relationship you know that's a
short-term mentality and I remember I
was I decided I was going to change that
and I would go meet with clients and
they wanted me to do all this work and
I'd say okay before we move on I want
you to know I'm extremely good at this
thing that you want me to do I'm pretty
good at this thing you want me to do I'm
acceptable and this thing you want me to
do and I'm terrible at this thing you
want me to do so what I recommend is let
me do these things
and hire somebody else and I'll partner
with them for these things
and the result was they actually wanted
to work with me more because I was the
only honest person in the room all the
other sales people all the other
companies that they were interviewing
said that they were great at everything
which everybody knows is a lie because
nobody's great at everything
and so the irony is the irony is by
admitting my weaknesses I actually built
trust and built and built better
long-term uh business relationships